ينضم الينا على كل المساعد المخرج في فيلم
المراهقون مروان مفرق مروان اهلا بك يسعد
صباحك معانا مبروك فوز في المرهقون بجائزه
منظمه العفو الدوليه في مهرجان برلين
السينمائي حدثنا اولا عن فكره الفيلم
صباح الخير عليكم
الفيلم ده كان يعني
صديق لنا عالم بعد الحرب من مشاكل
اجتماعيه بشكل اساسي مشاكل اقتصاديه بحكم
ما انتم عارفين الحرب ان الطبقه الوسط
تقريبا في عدن وفي اليمن ككل
الانهيار ادى الى
يعني يعني مشاكل اجتماعيه كبيره تخيلي ان
الفرد تقريبا كان في قبل 2015 دخلت الفرد
اذا قلنا مئه ريال مئه الف ريال كانت
ستعادل حوالي 4500 دولار الان دخل الفرد
نزل عن 80 دولار 60 دولار
مشكله كبيره يعني مروان
الوضع الاقتصادي مرهون بالوضع الامني غير
المستقر اصلا في اليمن فبالتالي اكيد كانت
مهمه التصوير صعبه ما الصعوبات والتحديات
التي واجهتكم اثناء التصوير الفيلم
بالنسبه لنا من من صادقه عدن بالنسبه لنا
بترحب باي عمل فني البيوت بتفتح ابوابها
لكنها ما ننكرش انه فاهم الوضع خصوصا انه
في خلال التصوير حصلت مواجهات مع اطراف
خارجه واضطرينا لايقاف التصوير لعده ايام
لكن الحمد لله بعد كده باشر العمل
ومن بدايتنا واحنا بنعاني من كل جوانب
الحياه يعني عشان الحمد لله
طيب مروان يعني لو نتحدث عن التركيز في
هذا الفيلم هل كان كان فكره الفيلم
التركيز على جردليه الاجهاض في المجتمع
اليمني ام التركيز على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي تدفع الناس للتدخلها عن
احلامهم
طبعا والقى هذا هو رمزيه
رمزيه فقط
زي ما طالع من السابق ان احنا في لغتنا
العربيه دائما
بنمثل بالاجهاض وكانه احلى
طيب مروان
اليوم الى اي حد انسى القضيه صوتها اعلى
من صوت المعركه وبالتالي تخاطبون فيها
العالم والغرب
لازم انتم عارفين السينما وهي توثق
لمراحل حياتيه في
بلدان كثيره
والان عبر
عبر 6 سينما صوت الانسان بيوصل اكثر من
صوت
البندق
عشان كده اعتقد ان انا لامسنا قلوب العديد
من الناس الذين شاهدوا الفيلم في مهرجان
لذلك
وصل
التصويت الجمهور لنا في مركز الثاني
تقريبا وهواء وهي جائزه انا اراها يعني من
اهم الجوائز
لكن اكثر ما اثار الاعجاب الجمهور العالمي
كان
حرص المخرج على اظهار اللقطات الطبيعيه في
عدن ولقطات بانوراميه تحرص على اظهار
معالم تاريخيه في عدن ما كانت ما الرساله
من وراء ذلك
رسالتنا بشكل اساسي ان عدم بتنوعها الديني
والثقافي من من عصور قديم يعني تتكلمي عن
مدينه اذا تكلمنا فقط التي مساحتها حوالي
سبعه متر سبعه كيلو متر مربع تحتوي على
هذه المدينه على كنائس وعلى معابد وعلى
وعلى عالم تاريخيه متنوعه جدا بسبب الحروب
التي مرت عليها اغلبها تعرض للاهمال
والتدمير لذلك نحن نحاول ان احنا
نلحق يعني بما يقولون
الباقي من المدينه الثقافي